today's guest is one of the funniest
people that I've ever seen I'm so
honored to be able to sit down with him
today he is the guest that I've been
trying to get I sent him a DM probably a
year ago and I'm just I had to come to
Australia to be able to sit down with
him he is the creator he's he's just
creative he has a new series on Netflix
called lunatics
he is he is the creator and the lead of
like nine different characters in Jonah
from Tonga and Summer Heights High which
are two of the most amazing shows you
might have to go a little deep into the
internet to find them but I think you
should Summer Heights High Jonah from
Tonga his new Netflix series lunatics
and I'm just really happy to be sitting
here with mr. Chris Lilley
[Music]
yeah dude I actually had a dream dude
like a couple nights ago that you were
we're like a restaurant or something I
was like a fast dream and you were
having like a maybe like a salad or
something I don't know is this him like
something you would eat what do you
think you would even eat you think I
don't even made but yeah
oh so you maybe within a salad a Tom I
don't know yeah
Mexican food so maybe yeah maybe it
wasn't I think it was you it was pretty
much you because I remember I was
meeting you at this restaurant and cuz I
was excited about meeting you and so I
was meeting you at this restaurant yes
and then it kind of cut - yeah it look
like you were having like a salad or
something yeah I wonder what made you
think that did I look like cuz you don't
know what I really look like you would
be thinking of the characters and stuff
so yes some of them I mean yeah I'm
trying to think of what character maybe
would be having like a salad maybe not
on the Earl of Havenhurst that night I
got a salad a Don he's a chaser later
yeah and what's wrong with him I feel
like he's on the spectrum yeah some sort
that is I'm that's what they call it
where I'm from other tizen yeah there's
something going on yeah I don't know
he's that kind of a victim of like
society a little bit you think well does
he do his own thing or is he like a yeah
I mean I feel like he's like
aspirational it's like everyone wishes
they had the balls to do this stuff that
he does and say this stuff he does yeah
but I think he gets away with it because
he's a little bit unaware of how
impactful it is which yeah maybe that's
the spectrum thing yeah it's kind of a
blessing to to be a little bit unaware
yeah once you get to aware stuff's not
that fun a lot of times yeah I think I
think people want to Bay him that's why
I kind of works yeah oh yeah I do a
little bit I think I think I was wish I
was a bit more like in
just felis huh yeah and his little
cousin - what's a guy's name Dylan yeah
how great was it to work with that kid
he's a cool kid yeah he's got laughing I
mean oh ha you could see some scenes
where it cuts away from him I noticed
because he was just gonna start laughing
yeah it was well because we just keep
rolling I think he didn't quite know
when we were on or not yes but he's a
really great kid
bet he picked up on a lot of the
language and he started like ad-libbing
and throwing in like oh it's great he's
say words and stuff so had to kind of
pull him back a bit
oh he's time to get crazy huh yeah but
he was just having fun it's great though
isn't it it must be fun to see that as
like and we're talking about lunatics
for people that haven't checked it out
it must be great to see like in the
beginning a guy like Dylan an actor like
him kind of you know learning his way
but by the end him starting to get that
confidence and stuff is that pretty cool
to see as a director yeah I'm always on
real there's a lot of things where we
drive off in this little really hard
yeah and I had to like pull out the
audio because as we drove off he was
like [ __ ] like man you can't like
swearing swearing at me and just like he
was just he got into it from that's
crazy yeah I wanted him to be a bit more
mute so yeah pull him out pull the audio
out you did take him aside sometimes a
little a little bit but I just usually
these people that we cast you kind of
just roll with whatever you you've got
like you've you've chosen them for a
reason and you just make the best of
what they have rather than trying to
shape them too much yeah and do you do
almost you're casting as well yeah well
I choose all the people that I'm I have
a really great team of casting people
that find them they literally go find
them off the straight they walk around
the streets and find them or they'll
just like rock up to schools or whatever
it's they'll go anywhere yeah because
it's so specific the kind of people we
need that you have to like search far
and wide yeah must be that it seems like
you almost need like kind of a guard and
you set up a garden
and you're kind of the the rabbit in a
way so it's like every the other people
are still amazing people and humans and
everything but it's almost does that
make any sense to you it's almost like
you have to have a place to put where
your creativity just is be able to kind
of flow through the yeah the the slalom
poles of the other characters yeah
that's it that's exactly it and it takes
a while to find those people also you
don't because they're real people I mean
not all of them some of them have some
acting experience but a lot of them are
real people and they're they behave a
certain way in the audition and then
when you're on set it's kind of like oh
[ __ ] there's Chris Lilley he's in a week
he's swearing at me and they kind of
become a bit different so you kind of
have to adapt to the new version of them
mmm because you can't talk them back
into the regular version sometimes it's
kind of hard I guess
I try to a little bit but then it makes
them lose confidence so sometimes I'm
like I'll fix it in the Edit but I mean
they do the the great thing about that
is then you get these magic moments
where they just they do these things
that actors never do like any like [ __ ]
that's so real and good and yeah is it
hard for you sometimes when you know a
moment like that is because I can
imagine they're probably times were in a
scene you know a moment just happened
that was so perfect that it's like is it
hard sometimes to your are you able to
notice those as they happen kind of
sometimes yeah you're in it you yeah you
say it when it happens yeah and then a
part of me is also like watching the
cameras and I've told those guys what to
do while they're doing things I can see
the way the cameras are moving at the
same time like oh [ __ ] they covered it
awesome god yeah like because we have
two cameras rolling at the same time and
yeah it's a weird thing and I can sort
of I'm editing it in my head as I'm
doing the same I don't know I'm not
turning myself Sam no it's not like
you're I'm just like it's a weird
process and you're lost that's gonna
work yeah echo only covered that and
then don't cut there it's that's
exciting
well there's not a lot of people that do
that have ever done really kind of with
you which you do you know it's rare
extremely rare I think man like I I
don't know I mean re now we're talking
about yesterday's that there's like you
know in the u.s. we have who's that guy
re yeah a little bit of Sacha Baron
Cohen but his some of his stuff is a
little more mean-spirited I think where
yours is just kind of like this this is
from a world that is just so it's all
about fun it seems like a lot of times
is that the Bible and set or does it get
sometimes a little bit too mad like you
have to manage so much that it's hard to
stay in the fun stuff it's probably more
it's a little bit more serious but it's
pretty relaxed and kind of peaceful it's
it's a really quiet thoughtful kind of
set like it's not
yeah that's not people I like often you
have like a first first date day that
will be yelling at everyone but in our
world it's just very peaceful nice he
talks quietly and it's just about
getting those moments cuz I've thought
it through so much before we get on set
mmm that I just know I need these little
moments so it's not like everyone's
laughing their heads off the whole time
yeah you kind of know like you sort of
you know how it's gonna come together
yeah it's it's more like peaceful than
hilarious on set yeah do um do you feel
like like recently I was thinking about
like what makes like why laughter like
important to me kind of you know or what
like it's always been to me and my wife
like and sometimes I was thinking that
you know I feel like laughter it's like
it was like when people were laughing
when I was young it was like the only
time that I kind of felt okay like for
some reason in my head I was always kind
of judging myself or I thought other
people thought something's wrong with me
you know and so I knew if they were
laughing then they couldn't be like not
liking me at the same time or something
you know like if I have those people
laughing there's no way they could be
laughing you know see seeing their smile
and hearing the joy come out of them and
also not liking me so it was like a
second of like peace in my in my head or
in my spirit or something
do you what it what is laughter kind of
been like for you or they are the
ability to make people laugh like what's
something you have any thoughts on any
of that from your own experience in life
yeah I mean it's so it's everything like
every friendship I have it's a bet about
laughing and making jokes about things
and just yeah I'm not really friends
with serious people but it's like it's
everything that's like so fun to just
even friends that I just text it's just
old jokes like and it's not like we're
like you know it's yeah everything's
funny it's just about saying the funny
side of everything
yeah similar thing like growing up I
just knew that there was a sort of power
in the idea of making the family laugh
and a fee I feel like you're the
youngest as well as something like are
you the youngest I have an older brother
yes I'm the youngest I got two two older
brothers and sister so I remember going
with a little one then yeah one so when
I was like this drug addict is a little
one oh yeah but it's yeah I remember
just being like five and then my brother
and sister were actually born in the
same year Ohio and same year January
December but anyway they were like I
thought you meant like May and July nah
I'm still it's like that's close um and
I think they call that Irish twins yeah
that well I was supposed to be triplets
to someone told me once yeah and I
wasn't it just me which is crazy cuz
I've always felt like there was
something else out there for me you know
I think they do an ultrasound the doctor
said that the other ones in there at one
point
I don't know told my mom that it was
triplets whenever they were going in
there and then nothing just me can you
have two that don't make it and one
comes out my mom would have told me well
I've always secretly thought I was a
twin and my mum is keeping it a secret
and I like hit her up with that a couple
years ago and she had him like a flinch
on if she sort of reacted when I said
it's a so you think maybe it could be
something that could be something this
yeah but I don't know if that's possible
I don't know much about
babies well moms like to keep secrets I
think when it comes to stuff like that
like about birth and like you know
family history and stuff that I think
they don't like to share all of that
yeah I guess it's in their day it was
more of a you just went off and did it
and didn't talk about it yeah they used
to sometimes they take a car down to the
you know maybe Byron Bay or something
you know and just have a baby down there
and come back and never even have a baby
yeah just like always
you know and a fad for a bit yeah just
into the toilet yeah that's it but I
mean you have people back in the day you
drive off to another town Boston and
give the kid to a charity or something
come back you know is this true yeah
that wasn't that long ago it was like
that in 50 years maybe yeah the only
thing my mom said once cuz I was talking
about how the circumference of my head
is really big mm-hmm I was like I've got
a massive head and I have to get extra
large hats and she's like and she was
like yeah I remember
so Oh apparently it was a big head when
it came in
oh I bet that never leaves him either
yeah I don't think about that the pain
of that yeah that's true man and is your
mom still alive yeah oh good yeah let's
think about it later when she's not yeah
she brought it up oh well then you're
safe man so you had the two older you
had the two older siblings
um yeah although I was gonna say like
they were like kind of pre I know that
would have been like teenagers when I
was about five and they're kind of
stressing out the parents are stressing
out about them because they're the
eldest and I have to like there was a
kind of stress eve ibed going on and I
remember just doing stupid gags and
making the family laugh which mostly
involved me like getting my dick out
yeah it's huge thing yeah that was big
when I was about five so there's a lot
of there was a lot of dick jokes going
on so and I bet it was fun for them too
to see a kid just partying with his dick
out and not like in a little way you
know just over yeah it was fun yeah man
actually when I was born I had like an
adult-sized penis on a child's body
did you yeah and so they had um like I
couldn't even sleep at night it would
hurt my back you know to sleep
well you know babies lay face down did
you just grow into it or has it growing
like no I'll do into it I grew past it
actually oh that was kind of
disappointing I wanna say now okay now
it's a child-size yeah now it's well
it's I mean it's you know like a healthy
kind of teenager sighs you know oh yeah
I think I think I haven't shown it to me
and I haven't seen a lot of thing that
just yeah yeah you think uh yeah I guess
at five years old your dick is like your
greatest wet it's like the coolest thing
you've ever known it's the best thing
out of it yeah
how great is that four times a day it's
it's so fun
yeah it's it's still fun it's like yeah
and people laugh at it my family thought
it was hilarious
yeah oh yeah that's great yeah there's a
lot of photos of it oh that's crazy
do you I remember it sometime I'll be
honest I would lay in the water in the
bathtub right and just pee straight up
in the air onto myself
yes I'm oh that's really good it was
good man I just oh you know what I just
saw the scene last night I was up
watching lunatics
wear the gear character the the the
large body realistic yeah yeah yeah he
loves that when he's showing the girl
page yeah you sitting down he thinks
it's amazing yeah and it is like it was
good man as exciting but yeah I remember
beans it was so much fun when you were
young man yeah making the family laugh
that is definitely a thing and then you
just become a big version of that I
guess yeah yeah did you um did you did
you realize like a consumer when I was
young I would make kids at school laugh
you know but I never realized that it
would be able to translate into doing it
like on a stage and stuff you know and
in a bigger environment yeah um did that
kind of happen for you like was there a
part where you realized like because
it's kind of scary to think that one of
your Talas something you do could be
like a marketable talent it's almost
like a
yeah it's almost cheesy yeah and we did
a little bit it's like yeah thing you
like I can have a normal job or I can do
this cool thing and yeah
yeah it's sort of worth it do you know
what like a lot of your characters have
they been with you since you were young
or some of them are brand new some of
them are things you just see off of
people on the street you're like oh I
could do that guy yeah it's usually a
combination of like things that have IDs
that you collect over a really long
period so it's not like it's ever one
person or one thing you've seen
sometimes it's like a leftover concept
from another show and that's the kind of
start of something but then it just
evolves along the way it's sort of out
of I feel like it's out of my control as
well like it kind of without trying to
like standing like a window it sort of
it comes alive and I don't really have
that much control of it it's like you
put the things in place you know what
they're gonna look like and there's the
story but the way they kind of move and
the way they sound and everything it
just comes together literally on the
first day when were on set look because
I had an idea for all the hair and stuff
and then but then the hair guy was like
well why don't you try this and it kind
of evolved really differently but you
don't get to see all the elements
together until literally like boom on
the first day like that Quentin
character we the first thing we filmed
was around the pool when he's having his
30th party hmm and I didn't really know
what he was gonna sound like like I kind
of I knew the character I knew what he
was about but he really just came alive
in that moment yeah around the pool with
with his mates and they're all going out
and and yeah I was like okay this is
this is so easy but sometimes people
don't get that and I often say to me are
I really like the voice or like I just
love how she moves or something I'm like
I didn't well how am i moving I didn't
know I see like if those things weren't
even part of the plan no I haven't
practiced I'm not I don't stand in front
of a mirror doing this kind of thing it
just it really just comes alive on the
day it sounds strange but
doesn't that strange to me I can
understand a little bit yeah well yeah
I've thought about it a lot and I know
what the story is and I know what
they're gonna say and the scripted lines
and everything but it the combo of
everything comes together on the day
yeah
like that the Gavin character he was
sitting on his bed back at the Adelaide
house and started talking but I was like
this is kind of how kids talk I think
and it was really slow and I was like it
didn't have the rhythm of something that
should be funny it was like I think it's
better to just make it real like make it
exactly how I think twelve-year-old boys
talk and that'll ultimately be funny out
then trying to be kind of quirky and
yeah have that funny rhythm that people
usually do because some of that I
noticing in in some of that it's like
there's something like going for the
joke and then there's something like I
trust that this will be funny later and
I just have to let it yeah like some of
this is a moment I notice in myself
where it's like there's a little thing
that goes over my head it's like if I
don't say anything else or make another
sound or another movement right here
then this is gonna land really really
good but if I do anything else if I look
or move or anything or say one more word
he's gonna it pops the balloon so I can
imagine there's some unique moments
where you're doing those characters
where you've probably really land in
like a special spot real like oh this is
a good spot for this character right now
yeah I know cool man because it's just
such a because then the reward is all
for the audience the reward is all yeah
you know they're gonna love it you know
it's so cool man the odd thing is you
have to really block out trying to
impress the people around you like the
crew and the cast if the the moments
awkward and not funny it's okay because
well it'll come together later but yeah
it's sometimes you have to really
remember it's not about pleasing the
people around you it's about the end
result
yeah so you get over that and just yeah
you know it's interesting man it's it's
uh
yeah because then you Louie get because
then it's interesting because part of
which or what I always noticed with my
original thing was to make the people
around me laugh yeah so it's then
whenever you're taping something
sometimes you have to sacrifice that
yeah to know that it's gonna make it's
gonna play better in this other other
way yeah I think when you sang making
this kids laugh at school I used to do
that but in a more kind of thought-out
planned way like I wasn't the class
clown the loud kid but I would plan out
a feeling like a funny scripted thing
that was gonna just do if I had to do a
speech I would write out something
really funny and then I just get up and
do something kind of shockingly funny
rather than I wasn't the kid yelling
[ __ ] out from up the back yeah but even
like primary school days I remember like
you had to
I don't know drawings and stuff I'd
always do something really funny that
incorporated like some in joke about the
teacher or something and but it was
planned out it wasn't sort of the loud
funny guy thing yeah which I like I
seems to be what I like to do yeah I was
never the class clown I was never like a
physical I was never physical I was
always like in my head I was like oh
this would be a time I was a verbal yep
I was more verbal than it was physical
yeah I thought one of the people around
me - laughs like I loved it the day that
you know you got into this patient the
head laughs was so fun do you remember
sometimes the fact that they would even
continue to let you go back up to the
front of the class yeah we'd already
been funny other times
yeah and ruin the teachers day and she's
again gonna let you go up and do any
yeah cuz the teachers just secretly
they're like kind of bored and wondering
what they're doing with their lives no I
hang on this is gonna this will be like
a little wrong but it'll it'll entertain
me
yeah sometimes there was no like
educational kind of content in what I
was saying but the teachers would give
me full marks they'd be like you made my
day and you just yeah often I've started
to work out that if you actually
pretended to bathe the teachers so I'd
get up and do like speeches as then and
they worked baver if key or some other
kind of controversial teacher at the
school
oh it was like it
can't leave the classroom but I said
these yeah that was fun that's fun man
it was it was so fun being young like
that just to be free you know yeah
that's good yeah
and there was no it didn't have to lead
to anything it was just that moment of
being funny and then you'd be thinking
about it about like yeah and then
reenacting with your friends are talking
about how funny it was that was so much
better now it's all captured so yeah it
spoils it some yeah and it gets judged
for weird raisins and analyze too much I
guess yeah well that's one of the cool
things that's been about podcasts it's
like all that [ __ ] is dying in the u.s.
like all of that like because there was
no fan base for it it was just like
clickbait online you know there was no
real you know people judging stuff it
was just losers sitting around at home
with not just on their computers and
people lonely people writing articles it
wasn't actual funny people who liked to
laugh expressing themselves because
they're busy living their lives yeah but
now it's like with podcasting so many
more people are just having a good time
again and so much less judgmental in the
u.s. anyway I'm noticing it growing but
I don't know if it's if it says if it's
the same here probably yeah I guess it
would be it seems to be it seems to be
getting really huge the whole podcast
thing and I can see why yeah it's it's
uncensored and you really feel like you
get to know the person you're listening
to yeah yeah that's it's good did you so
when you make your family laughs and you
were young but you make like your mother
and father laugh - or now yeah yeah and
I were the main ones laughing oh really
yeah that's cool
was it fun to make your parents laugh
like who was the funnest to make laugh
in your family like probably my oldest
brother yeah and I mean he would make me
laugh like so we had a kind of instilled
oz like we had a good thing together
yeah one of my favorite things that he
did when I was little was where I used
to go to bed really early and he was
teen I just so he would stay up but it
was really dark and used to sneak in my
room and like jump on my bed and pretend
that he was my Chinese mother and did
this like ridiculous stereotypical
accent but the whole concept was that
the Chinese mother used to sneak in at
night to try to steal me back because I
was actually a Chinese kid that had had
an operation like my eyes wide and then
he'd do the whole like I can't do the
accent or get in trouble but yeah here
I'll do a lovely try okay yeah
oh oh you're coming home there it is
okay yeah yeah this is your Chinese
father yeah anyway he used to do that
and they need run out of the room and
then he come back in as himself and
they'd be like ah Chris the um there was
this Chinese woman running down the
driveway she seemed really like freaked
out what I know I'd have to pretend I
didn't know of anything about it and and
they used to make me laugh so much he
did a lot of lies but my Chinese mother
was one of my favorites that's so cool
that he did that because then it leaves
you cuz then he goes to bed or whatever
and it leaves you and your bed laying
there yeah with this expansive idea what
can be funny yeah I mean that was a
woman out in the world that's a fake
woman there's your brother who's just
asleep in the other room that you laying
there with your eyes and your spirit
wide open it was so exciting like I'm
still like thrilled by it I mean that's
an example of him bang hilarious today
so but I think it kind of got me excited
about those ideas do you think that like
humor like creates a special bond
between like family members and stuff
like that yeah yeah definitely it's sort
of I can't imagine people that don't
find things funny like that's my whole
relationship with the family is
everything's a joke like iMessage my mom
like every day and it's always something
funny like it's yeah I mean there's lots
of in jokes and sort of funny stories
but it yeah it definitely bones people
together do you guys did your family
have a good like regular connection as
well and then you also have the humor
connection or is the humor connection
kind of like a does it kind of suffice
for you guys is the way you guys kind of
emotionally connect to each other if
that's how that's a bizarre question
yeah I think yeah this it's not two
things there's like we talked about
neela stuff but it always has a bit of a
funny take yeah like and it's that kind
of pissed take Australian humor thing
where you kind of like putting someone
down yeah yeah my mum's things about how
or where I used to say we're all thick
like not very smart and so that's her
whole thing is that she in the family
she's the one that had the thick kids I
mean especially after hearing about how
viky ahead was it's what I am yeah she
said no not a bit gate this one's gonna
be a bit thick at that mode yeah so she
still runs with that angle that like
we're really stupid she's not wrong and
she must be really proud of you huh yeah
I think she's really into it yeah she's
she yeah really appreciates it and I
think so I we don't really talk about it
in that way so much yeah but yeah she's
always telling me people that she works
with and friends and stuff that are
loving it so I think she's into it
that's cool that must be for a mom
that's pretty cool yeah my mom said she
had wore a t-shirt of mine cuz on first
came to saw me she hadn't seen me
perform in about five years until a
couple of weeks ago and she um I gave
her just like a merch t-shirt you know
she was just enamored by she talks about
every day now yeah it's pretty pretty
lame but uh but she likes it you know
yeah and she wore it somewhere and some
gay young guy came up and said something
to her and yeah it was just like the
most yeah there's something for me
anyway about making my mom feel proud
that really just like makes me feel okay
you know makes ya like a different level
of okay that I'm normally able to make
on my own you know because the kind of
thing we do it takes a while to get into
the to get to the level where it's like
your job and it's perceived as a
successful thing so yeah there's many
years where I I'm sure parents are like
what the [ __ ] like I [ __ ] this up yeah
I gave birth to this thick-headed baby
yeah doing dirty riddles what's going on
yeah I shouldn't have lost a big job
but yes sumo I had a similar thing when
my mom
there's the characters Jame the
schoolgirl oh yeah first time I played I
sent a photo to my mom going this is
what I'm doing and she was like what the
[ __ ] like this is wrong because it's
like my son's just I was a young girl
it's really weird and she said her reply
to me was I wouldn't be showing that
around at work and then when the show
came out it was like really popular in
Australia and my mum bought a t-shirt
with Jame on it and she was walking
around wearing the t-shirt with me on it
it's like how you changed your tune oh
she's into it now she is did um
you know what's interesting is a lot of
my friends still don't know about summer
high tide I regard it as and that whole
series I saw it about a year and a half
ago for maybe two years ago for the
first time I'd never even heard about it
and I was so shocked when I saw it and I
was like oh my god this is like
everything I've ever wanted to laugh at
in one space and and I couldn't believe
that I hadn't just been I hadn't known
about it you know and how did you find
out about it just random somebody said
somebody said hey man you have to watch
this then I heard it again like a week
later from somebody just randomly and
then I was like okay this thing's coming
into my little universe and I got to
know about it and it uh-oh too because
that show like I made that in Australia
for our local network and you know I
just never thought it would go beyond
Australia really fact that you're
watching it in America a year ago is so
it spins me out like how could that I
could imagine I could imagine that a
decade later or something to me have
something still swirling and even
blowing people's minds it blew my mind
it was like I never seen anything like
this since I was a kid and they had a
show called in living color when I was
young that was really big in the States
yeah um but yeah to this day I think
it's probably the funniest you know and
going off into that series you know what
mr. G and the other character like he's
got it from Tong just look at my dick
dot just the whole just how many [ __ ]
it's so weird it's everything that I
felt like was funny to me as like a as a
human you know and I couldn't express it
and so somebody had like captured
disability let's just make it perfect
man yeah somebody will just really get
it yeah does it make you laugh I mean
III I'd never go back and watch anything
that I really do have done but does it
make you laugh sometimes oh there's
sometimes a character like well the
voice of one and we'll pop in your head
yeah makes you feel good all right
definitely like because if you have a
look at Instagram and people make all
these memes a little video yeah and the
thing is I forget that I've done stuff
but I relive it through those videos and
things someone sent me as you may one
the other day and I was like I was like
[ __ ] that's fine I was losing my [ __ ]
yeah it was just Jame like having a go
at the principal for for not giving her
the hillford medal I don't if you've
seen that show but yeah so her whole
thing is that they've given it to a fat
lesbian board um and she's really like
I can't believe and she says yeah I'm
like the hottest student to have a grace
you [ __ ] playground and I don't know
I just some reason that line made me
laugh but yeah I I do laugh at it I love
it yeah I don't yeah you sit around and
laugh at it not an ego way but that's
that's I mean that's just a testament to
our entertaining it is I think that it
can even come back and make you laugh
you know yeah and that's okay it's you
know it's it's cool sometimes there'll
be a moment I'll see in a joke I'll you
know I'll see online or something oh but
yeah dude that got me man I was yeah
that guy did a good job
it's not like I'm thinking I did a good
job yeah like I'm thinking that guy did
a good job that's a good way to explain
it yeah I don't feel like I'm not
responsible for that so yeah I'm not
bragging when I say that it's like mmm
that person was funny it's hard to keep
our ego out it's uh or we might cutting
on the AC for a second we're just
cutting it on over there on that wall
just put it at like 19 yeah if you don't
mind bud and always uh the open or -
he's a he that's what he is he's a
comedian but he's like the best yeah
he's been you guys on tonight a real
champ yeah if you want to jump on stage
man you know you man welcome to practice
something people would lose their minds
that uh is it hard being like a legend
in your country must be is it kind of
scary sometimes a little bit
it is a little bit but I'm pretty
low-key and I don't do any press and
stuff so I'm not kind of known as like
me as myself so I can kind of walk down
the street but at the moment because the
loonatics things been really big I do
get stopped a lot and it's a bit full-on
yeah there's a little bit of a like
paparazzi thing that happens here which
can be a bit this is scary it's just
scares me it's scary like I you know I
don't care the fights just me walking
around the streets and stuff but the
photos are not that weird but it's scary
when you see them and you hear the
camera and stuff and it freaks me out
what does that mean oh here the camera
people show up yeah oh yeah the PAP
thing yeah yeah
but yeah it's scary if I go to an event
or something and people are all hyped up
and excited and you're like [ __ ] work
how am I gonna get away from this yeah
sometimes it just it can be a bit
full-on it's interesting how is it been
tough for you to like was there moments
in your career where you've had to like
battle your own ego like one thing I
noticed for myself is my ego it's kind
of a separate animal than me you know it
lives inside of me and it's like it can
be a victim to all the things that go on
in the world you know you know it's kind
of like a sugar lizard I call it like
it'll just you know just goes for the
sugar all the time it's just the way
it's built have you had any and recently
I've had to just make sure to myself I
start to do some meditation is just make
sure to just keep my mind and focus
what's going on my job just to make
people laugh and and not get caught up
in anybody else's ideas of what I am do
you have any do you have any thoughts
about that during your career or notice
any stuff about your own ego or anything
I think like I'm all the opposite like I
kind of can't get my head around the the
interest in it and I don't know I
probably should be more confident about
it I'm probably a bit down on myself
about the whole thing
yeah if ever right there's like TV
Awards nights and I go to those and like
what am I doing here like I'm not part
of this like who raised people well you
know I'm not saying that to be I'm so
super humble whatever it's just
genuinely my
thing I'm not yeah I don't hate that hey
guys is it a discomfort so say you're at
a thing like that right because if I go
to something like that in Los Angeles I
feel uncomfortable oh yeah like I feel
like yeah I don't know I feel like maybe
these people are judging me or I just
feel some sort of uncomfort which is
kind of fine with me it's kind of some
of the uncomfort is what keeps me in a
place where I feel like I'm able to be
funny anyway is that the kind of thing
you feel or you just feel like oh this
isn't my vibe or do you like if you go
to something kind of fancy is there yeah
I think because there's I feel like
there's an expectation for me to pay a
little pace of the showers so I feel
like when I'm at those things people
like can you make us feel the way that
we do when we watch you dressed up and
in the show and I'm like that's it's not
what I do but like I I knew that you
would get it that's why I like talking
to you but normally I don't do those
kind of interviews and things or go on
TV talk shows and stuff because I know
that there will be that expectation hmm
I see what you're saying yeah well I
pretty yeah man I'm so grateful you uh
that you that were able to do this man
yeah I just couldn't believe I could be
such a fan of so I've never been a fan
of anything that much of my whole life
is almost bizarre dude I was like man
I'm such a like what's going on with me
dude I thought I was gonna go to like a
second per buddy or something you know
I thought I was gonna sprout another
dick or something you know or the other
beard or something on my neck you know I
thought it was pretty cool you just yeah
just made me laugh so much man oh good
that's like the best thing ever like to
know that isn't it fun making people
laugh it's crazy isn't it it's the best
yeah it's so good it's well that's the
whole Drive and the reason what we're
doing it it's it's just to make people
feel that that thing yeah I mean you
want them to feel a lot of things you
want them to be just excited and
inspired and kind of maybe sad sometimes
or all sorts of things but the main
thing you want them to do is just laugh
and find it really funny so yeah it's
cool yeah it is cool van der SIA there's
something it's so funny laughter because
people shake and they make a noise and
it's such a it's almost
you like Harry Pollock it's not like
your Harry Potter but the process of it
is the the result of it it's almost like
it's like a magic or something you know
yeah it's very weird I mean you would
have that immediate things just standing
in front of people in there making
noises and shaking their buddies at you
yeah that's true you get it more
immediate on stage that's right I forget
you cuz you you it says online you did
stand-up yeah I did start doing that
that's sort of how it got into it but um
did you find that it wasn't your medium
kind of doing it did you find like cuz
I'm sure you learned from it like okay
this is this but did you then find okay
I work better in this other yeah I think
I prefer doing TV but it was a that was
how I got into it oh that was the
stepping stone because I would stand
it's there's nothing better than there's
there's no better way of reaching the
like creating something and reaching
people than stand-up because you're just
you're thinking of everything you're
standing there saying it it's reaching
them immediately everything else has
layers of stuff that takes away from
that so I found it a really good way to
start things and that's then that
morphed into be doing characters on
stage aha I mean I always did characters
back in school days and right and
priming my whole life just always did
characters but then stand-up I did the
more traditional thing and then I moved
into that like annoying singing songs
stand up and then I was like actually
I'm just gonna do characters well so I
get on stage and I talk about a person a
type of person and then I'd sort of been
around and become that person yeah and I
was like oh this is the things working
like yeah and then start to make little
short films and things about those
characters and then that spawned me off
into TV so yeah I definitely did it for
a little while and it was you got to
have balls to do that though it's like
so scary just to jump up in front of
people yeah you get used to it but well
I think what's scary to me is to make a
character and like put it on Instagram I
put her on social media put it on that
to me feel so scary for some reason like
they're parts of me that I think would
love to do it oh now to do it you should
do that
yeah it's but for some reason that is so
scary to me as opposed to getting up in
front of people is much less scarier
yeah I guess it's just anything you get
used to it it's like if you're scared of
flying you do it all the time and
suddenly you're not it's like that well
you know and you don't want to think it
is Chrisman is for me if they're there
live then I know immediately for me to
give something to a place and let it be
seen and not be able to be there and
know if they are there laughing yeah
that for me is there's some fear in that
like like I need to be right there to
know if they laugh or not it's I'm okay
almost if they don't it'll hurt me but
yeah but to put it somewhere like in a
television and let them see it but not
be able to actually be there and see
them as they see it and know if they
laugh yeah that's something that's
really like to me very not comfortable
yeah okay and the thing with TV also is
is it's expensive to make it so there's
a lot of expectation on it and a lot of
kind of buildup and hype and and people
love to say that you fail that at it so
this is yeah like expectation thing yeah
I kind of don't get involved in that did
you do you ever consider going to the
going to live in the States
at any point I'm not really like after
the first show I did we can be heroes
that then obviously like in the States
all the agents start calling and people
are like you need to make a movie here
and all that kind of stuff so that
happened but I could just sense that
there was gonna be too much like
involvement from people and yeah and
everyone just wants you to do more of
the same but they want to tell you how
to do it mm-hmm so it's kind of like and
then I just was like I'm gonna do that's
when I did something I'd say I came back
and did that and I didn't want to go to
auditions and all sucks that scene I
just loved
I'm just driven by a different thing
which is to create something out of
nothing and then see the whole process
through from the beginning to the end
and be the person driving that yeah
that's very different experience to
auditioning and being it's
one else's feeling or whatever it is
yeah I got offered some roles recently
and I just at first I was like yeah I
got excited but then I had to go back
and apologize and say I just can't do
this I said yeah yeah I'd like to be a
creator I don't want to do something
unless I for some reason it feels scary
to do something of somebody else's I
only feel comfortable doing something in
my own almost yeah it's a different
motivation and people don't get that
because it sounds so like prestigious
and stuff like drug in someone else's
film and people still say to me now
they're like oh you should act one day
I'm like what do you mean I'm like
playing [ __ ] six different characters
like not act in a movie like in someone
else's movie like get in a movie with
like Meryl Streep and [ __ ] I'm like yeah
dude I think I'm I'm already acting
anyway that would be so dope to see you
in Bridges of Madison County - oh yeah
that'd be the most I'll just be laughing
imagine doing the same with Meryl Streep
hard work she a [ __ ] to me she's pretty
though it's always about us because she
had like a motherly thing and also like
a womanly thing yeah yeah yes she's a
GILF yeah she's like a perfect storm
like i breastfeed offer definitely
absolutely who's someone you breastfeed
you think off of it's over the age of 60
Judi Dench do you know that is no I'm
just you know someone I was 60 I don't
know if I want to breastfeed is she a
Dame Judi Dench yeah was that oh I've
left off the title yet there's a
religious figure she's uh she's an
actress oh she's an actress yeah no I
don't want to suck her what breastfeed
her yeah [ __ ] who was there was Betty
White but she's so old yeah I mean I
definitely would go there but not with
Betty yeah um but I put a straw in the
tit I think now that I think about if
it's really old
you'd have to yeah anything over 50 I
don't think I'm putting my lips on and I
just you know
Oh mister now your character Becky I
think is probably one of my favorite
ones I think especially when they made
fun of her in the dorm like I could
really relate to that and that's as far
as I am on the show I'm just through I
think I'm now through episode 3 maybe of
lunatics and some of it I found myself
having to go back because there's more
there's a lot going on sometimes so it's
almost like I have to listen to the
wording again like to hear everything
you're saying
yeah but where what's up with Becky how
is she doing today is she doing okay
she's never gonna be that okay like yeah
I've got a pretty difficult situation I
just like the idea that just go up
basically kinda has a disability and
everyone's ignoring it and pretending
she's just the tall girl yeah and she's
got a lot of issues and a family just
told her how amazing she is trying to do
the right thing they've like given her
this false confidence so at the point
when we meet her she's kind of faking it
so much but she's just a bundle of
insecurities and as the show goes on she
gets really involved in becoming a
YouTube vlogger so she gets this
confidence boost out of all her
followers online and things start to
take off Wow and so she's just it's that
young girl being so insecure and and
just there's no way she's not an
attractive girl she's got a really she's
got massive legs she can barely do the
ankles are very big massive ankle make
it bigger it seems like in some of the
scenes you're the first person to say
that they don't get big event I think
there's just more shots of them so cuz
there's a couple scenes where it look
like she put on about 40 pounds mhm yeah
does she just has some bad outfits but
she just is never gonna be the popular
girl and all the kind of she's always
gonna struggle in life and I just like
that concept that the dorm life is just
everyone is just relentlessly attacking
her every episode she just is bullied I
don't know why I found that funny but
yeah because it's actually quite tragic
but to me it's funny she she hits a head
a lot on things
yeah well it's so grateful her dad came
and put it you know uh yeah the boy he
loves her yeah the best he's a busy dad
though he does his best and not can you
relate to two girls if you're a dad it's
probably hard yeah and he had the
perfect daughter and then the kind of
freaky daughter so it kind of has tried
to compensate for it by being super nice
but you can only build someone's
confidence up so much yeah the reality
is she's gonna have a hard time I'm
curious to see now man now yeah method
in the character yeah she's she has a
bit of a love interest thing the
basketball guy I'm guessing oh no don't
tell me don't tell I don't tell you that
okay yeah it's she she just wants to be
a normal girl and it's a struggle yeah
that was that was a lot of fun I guess
everybody had that did you have like um
did was there anything like I have like
a big nose I big ears kind of like those
are things like I was insecure about
like when I was growing up you know that
always like and a nose is hard because
it's you [ __ ] have to show it to
everybody you know like yeah it's yeah I
think I also have a big nose and big E's
is it
I don't think about ears that much but
now I know you made me think about it oh
sorry yes
yeah you seem like you have a normal
look to me not a big nose in the big big
ears but when you're a teenager all that
stuff is so much bigger on your face
anyway yeah and you had the big dick
thing to say oh yeah thank God I had
that but nobody wanted to hear about
that after the big nose and ears they
were like yeah yeah or god nobody gets
all three big you know yeah no nobody's
that much her legend yeah um yeah I mean
I'm trying to think of what else really
so you don't have any pets oh you do
that pets you said I don't have pets but
I have two rainbow lorikeets that come
to visit me every day and it's the same
ones you said yeah the same two because
one has like a squashed up foot like an
injured foot oh yeah like somebody from
Game of Thrones Connor I'll show you the
photo cuz he's my screensaver on my
phone but um yeah they're really
friendly Birds they're big thing in
Australia like
loves them I think everyone loves them
they've got good personalities do you
think that they know that you're on on
telly and everything like that or no I
thought about that
I reckon they might be on to it but like
literally I go away for months and I'll
come back and they're there but yeah
they just cuz they literally come into
my house and get in my sink and walk
like I land on the edge of my laptop
like they've seen me naked they're like
we're really intimate though artistic it
sounds like yeah they sound like
photographers oh they almost sound like
a little bit of well yeah they may be
maybe they're taking some photos I don't
know that I did cross my mind that maybe
um because there's some other like
famous people who live in the area like
Hugh Jackman's got a place down in Bondi
oh wow and I've always thought maybe the
birds they're going to him because
sometimes they come to mind they've got
this powdered [ __ ] on their eyes and
like it's Jackman feeding them and then
they're coming to me yeah are they doing
cocaine down by Jackman well yeah yeah
there's some like grameen up down there
by Jackman's and this is like powder on
the noise yeah I could see that man a
lot of birds the everybody thinks
they're doing good [ __ ] all the time
that's a crazy thing man yeah this is
smart bird so it wouldn't surprise me
dude I remember like when I was growing
up they have in America they have a
disease it's called Down syndrome you
know and it's like people have like uh
it's kind of like people just I don't
know what it is really but they had a
good buddy my when I was young that had
it you know and so we were children you
know we were good friends and I remember
people always thought that he was and he
would do we would go drink alcohol
sometimes I'm like he would do you know
steal [ __ ] just regular kitchen and
people thought that he was always doing
like only sweet stuff like he always got
the benefit of the doubt yeah you know
yeah people always thought like all he's
doing probably doing a puzzle or
something you know he's with his
grandparents like any [ __ ] was and he
was yeah he was raising hell you know
it's like some things like birds or
whatever they always get the benefit of
the doubt you know yeah we need to
analyze that more carefully yeah
just cuz you got colored feathers
doesn't mean like you're not a [ __ ]
yeah it doesn't mean you're not really
raising hell somewhere yeah they could
be somewhere doing who knows what
I like - I'd like to follow them
I bought a drawing and my thought was
I'm gonna like fly it off the balcony
and follow the lorikeets mm-hmm but this
so fast the lower kids are so fast plus
as soon as they hear the drawing they
fly no it's it hasn't worked so far
because they they haven't nest and they
have babies and stuff because they
always bring their baby to me when
they've had one and oh my god this is
definitely a game of Thrones guy I
wanted to take the drone and find out
where the nest whoa oh
imagine that yeah he said you've been
watching them following them yeah I
think Abby could have had like a virtual
reality drawing and then I could go to
the nest and like reach out yeah spend
time there like I knew would feel like I
was flying with them daddy's home yeah
yeah oh my Chinese when we coming to get
you in the middle of the night that's
how I deal with the babies
yes I'm the baby's Chinese another yeah
I like that wouldn't that be crazy man
if one day you wake up like in heaven or
something and you come to you just look
in the mirror and you're an actual
Chinese on Oh Oh that'll be amazing I
don't know if I'd love that
I'd be so surprised is that what happens
you gotta heaven in the real you is
revealed I bet there has to be some sort
of Revelation or some sort of like an
exposure almost like you expose a photo
where you see oh this is yeah you
thought you're gonna write this this is
the real thing yeah this is what was
going on you were [ __ ] around you
know you were playing with these birds
and the balcony in the head you know
yeah cameras in their eyes
yeah yeah you were feeding Birds see to
a camera like in five years man
and you have to watch the footage and
Anna and you look like such an idiot to
you like you just keep feeding this
hammer yeah seriously that could happen
was um was there ever like a entertainer
from the states that reached out like
Jim Carrey or somebody like that that
was like oh I have to do something with
this guy I can imagine that that's
probably happened to you over the years
the odd that I've reached out to me yeah
and they wanted to like they were just
real keen on trying to work with you and
and key means excited I just learned it
like two days ago but yeah they were
excited to try and have you in their
project or I mean even though it wasn't
something you were looking for but yeah
there's been a little bit of that but
sort of just more coming from like
casting people of directors and stuff
rather than actual like artist artists
like a lot of them I actually
essentially like people too there's been
big big name people who are fans of the
shows and have reached out yeah it
happens if a v8 um but I can't feel like
a [ __ ] naming who those people are
oh yeah not about asking who they are
yeah yeah no I'm just asking if that's
ever happened I guess like yeah I guess
I was just kind of thinking like cuz if
I thought of like one of my favorite
movies is Dumb and Dumber right yeah so
I thought well would you ever see you
know is that something that like a David
Spade the other day was telling me that
Chris Farley yeah got offered the role
of and there's something about Mary yeah
that Ben Stiller played the main guy oh
yeah yeah and I just never knew that it
just blew my mind because then I start
thinking of that movie and if Chris
Farley plays Ben still it's just
interesting you know yeah so I guess I
was just wondering if there had ever
been like a unique role or if somebody
had ever or just if it had ever happened
not like specifics you know there's been
a few roles it's it's never like the
handsome laid it's always like the kind
of game it's like the Freak the weird
but Laurel something like the kind of
yeah one of them was like a it was like
James Franco's pee or something but but
obviously was some like camp weirdo yeah
like I get those roles like yeah they've
seen some lights are they like can you
do mr. J but we're not going to say that
but right you gotta keep that magic for
yourself yeah
yeah I don't do that yeah yeah I don't
like to outsource my magic if I have any
you know or not magic but whatever I do
have you know yeah I don't want to just
put it in whatever I'd rather save it
and maybe hope that it you know that it
can be good somewhere specifically yeah
I'm the same
so well so you're listening three
episodes yeah yeah
and also I also haven't seen uh I
haven't seen the heroes movie that you
did yeah
yeah I can tell the bits you don't think
she kind of just your eyes glazing I
know it's hard to hide it huh yeah I now
feel bad sometimes but you can't watch
everything
no Yukon is a lot of stuff yeah and I'm
kind of glad I haven't seen everything
we're goes in there's some things that I
can be like you know still amazed by
like I'm only on season two of Game of
Thrones oh yeah I'm on season one are
you yeah I'm awesome but I'm excited
that that's ahead of me because everyone
told me to watch it so I was like no I'm
not coming to you yeah now I'm secretly
watching it you don't watch Scarface for
the first time three years ago [ __ ] I
don't think I've seen it I'm saying are
you serious
it's a good [ __ ] you man you [ __ ]
just outdid me I waited my whole life to
watch people kept telling me you got to
watch it it's like a legendary flick I
haven't seen Top Gun haha [ __ ] you man
oh you can end up in hell brother I
could make it yeah what about Thelma and
Louise have you seen it saying it yeah
the other one was mad man everyone kept
raving about it and I was like no not
watching it and then I secretly watched
it and I liked it mmm but I didn't want
to tell anyone so like had to get three
like seven seasons cuz I didn't want to
be in season three and go it's pretty
good and they're like I'll have any
Saints A's and Sikhs like you don't that
yeah so I do a lot of secret watching oh
I see what is uh what about a league of
their own have you seen that movie that
is Madonna in that yeah yeah that's Tom
Hanks is in it right the lesbian lady
yeah I could have seen you playing over
one of the characters in that huh yeah I
can I would say that yeah a big butch
lesbian yeah
or not big she could be just be right
yeah but yeah a little husband yeah
lipstick lesbian but like in a Chinese
city maybe I'll see ya that's my dream I
could see you be like the hottest woman
in like a Chinese village kind of
yeah my Chinese woman I mean I just say
I could see that like I could see if I
showed up in like a village like outside
of Shanghai you know a couple hundred
miles out there being like oh this is
our queen you know yeah yeah I can say
that say that
that'd be great actually yeah they'll be
really good I wonder what kind of
sometime if I could be like if I had to
be a woman what type I would be I would
be like I think at the bus driver you
know oh yeah butch yeah tough you know
bowling at night and yeah but she's
gonna feminine side yeah she can sort of
wear a dress on Friday night
yeah I'm Friday night she likes to wear
a dress sometimes to go down to the VFW
or something yeah the VFW here know it's
like Veterans of Foreign Wars it's were
like oh yeah what do they call it here
we got the RSL yeah good on the RSO and
maybe have a cocktail
they re yeah I can see there do some
video games or something in a dress that
you do some swing dancing I reckon yeah
but you'd be sort of attractive when you
want it to be mostly butch yeah mostly
just [ __ ] riding the rails yeah out
there just getting people where they
need to go would be fun yeah you just do
that for a day be a real woman yeah I
think in a couple years you'll be oh do
I think in a couple years like with all
these hormones and stuff they have now I
think just chuck it on for a day yeah
Chuck on a [ __ ] puss in a couple tits
you know yeah you'd hit though you know
go watch you know something a film with
that you know walk take a run yeah I'd
like to run as a woman I better go for a
jog yeah the sports bra yeah yeah just
let it all spit if you want yeah see
always got butch woman yeah that's true
because if yeah well being a pretty
woman would scare me I think it see much
so much pressure that would be hard work
yeah I don't and not always having to
look kind of like perfect each of soup
real perfectly yeah it would make me
nervous mr.
yeah yeah think about that everybody's
staring at you and it happens when
you're young and then it makes you that
would make me so nervous yeah I'd be
hard yeah I don't know what else I would
be maybe I could see you also being like
the guy like on a soccer team that likes
it is in a wheelchair that on the side
oh yeah anything that he's in the team
but they just it's like a sympathy thing
and they wheel him out once a year and
kind of wheel him down the grass down
the grass or yeah it's like oh cuz the
field is a little bit oh yeah
it's a cheese field yeah yeah it's down
here a little yeah I could do that I
don't think it's a mother oh I could
also see you doing like a Robin Hood
type of oh yeah I could see man like a
road rage yeah Rob so the written gives
to the pool yeah does he swing through
that's tahzan isn't like climb trees and
she does he Robin Hood yeah I could see
you being like Tarzan's brother that
wants to do something different to get
out of the jungle a little alternative
like yeah he's a bit of an emo time it's
skinnier got ya yes he's not that hot
dude and she comes to the other force
and I gives him books and [ __ ] and
cassette tapes even though he's another
player yeah this is always a bit
depressed yeah I could see you doing
that it's security options do you think
sometimes like dude do you know when a
character comes in your head you like
like four lunatics you know did you have
them all planned out and the obviously
you had ideas and you said once you get
to set you get in makeup it grows even
more but but was there another character
that you went to set with it you guys
did that you left on the floor oh not
that we got that far with but in the
writing stage I had like about eight
characters all armed and then I kind of
had to narrow it down I remember doing a
drawing actually and I'm not even good
at drawing stuff and it was like of all
of the characters to get on and so I
could just look at the lineup and was
imagining it how it would work and then
there was a couple of characters that I
just thought nah you kind of crossing oh
it's like a little too
that it's similar to something you've
done before that's the thing because
I've done a lot of characters soi-yah
different I've done you know once you do
long red hair you can't do that again so
you got to think of different hairstyles
and yeah so a few of them I got rid of
but then as some of the great ideas I
sort of morphed those ideas into the
current characters mmm
so yeah yeah it's hard to find new
characters I bet huh cause once you've
done like a guy if it's a gay guy you
can't it's like you could do another one
but it's it still kind of sticks on that
it'll stick to the other one that's it
yeah it's hard and there's always a
little bit of a crossover because
there's certain things you find funny or
interesting so you're always kind of
going down the same path a little bit
yeah but that's actually the challenge
now is to make it different cuz then
done a lot a lot of characters now is
that kind of I mean even though it's
like I'm sure there's a great sense of
pride with that is there a little bit of
like is it almost kind of a bummer
sometimes that you've gone through like
a lot of humanity and character you know
that you that you have that much of a
body it is cuz sometimes you got a
slightly different take on it and I'm
like oh that would be better I'm like
you haven't you kind of did that look
you've done like the fashion thing or
the skate thing or whatever it is surf
or whatever the kind of world is yeah or
I've done an Asian woman before and I'm
like I currently do that again yeah but
I do bring characters back like there's
been a lot of like spin-offs and stuff
yeah they come back well if seen I'll
think of some Oh some of the stuff I've
seen I've seen like Jonah from Tonga and
I've seen I mean yeah it was just too
much sometimes uh but so good and it
helped me learn about like Tongan people
a little bit unlike the characters and
it gave me like a sense of like what it
would actually be like to be at a school
when you're young like that you know and
when he goes and lives with his auntie
yeah [ __ ] god I [ __ ] miss that family
dude you know it's the family's the
[ __ ] auntie man it feels so real like
it feels like that that they exist out
there somewhere still yeah does he [ __ ]
up to you too yeah to me it does yeah
it's yeah and it's kind of yeah I'm kind
of caught up caught up in the illusion
of it as well you
weirdly yeah I can totally I could
totally imagine that you know a lot of
kids he says their imagination is
changing because you know with social
media with computers and stuff it's
different like you can create stuff
actually more so your imagination is
almost like the processor now is in the
machine yeah whether than it used to be
have to be in your head you know it's a
little bit scary I wonder if they'll
ever have
you know if we'll ever be able to do
some of the stuff that you know you and
I been able to do growing up like if the
medium will change so much that they
won't even look at why is this guy
pretending to be this character when he
could just you know yeah you're right
that's why isn't it it's already kind of
evolved a lot in the last 10 years or so
so yeah does it scare you a little bit
no I just kind of roll with it like it's
funny doing the showed Netflix because
they have this sort of the episodic
thing but all the apps kind of run
together for most people most people sit
back and watch like one and a half
episodes or something and then the the
episode length time it's it's so we sort
of they're basing it on the model of old
broadcast TV but it's actually already
evolving into this thing it's just this
linear entertainment thing that people
just tap into when they want to and yeah
we're sort of in this weird transition
where it's a little bit there's a little
bit left over from the past yeah I mean
kind of like yeah like when films first
started and it was like vaudeville
performers and [ __ ] and they were like
it was all just like watching a
theatrical production like you were kind
of looking at it for one perspective and
then it kind of evolved and people were
like well [ __ ] we could get different
angles and we could edit this and yeah
anyway I don't know why I'm saying like
I know I'm talking about you just saying
it's change
yeah it's evolving and so I've I started
doing 25-minute episodes or whatever and
they went to air once a week and now I'm
doing this kind of long thing that just
keeps flowing together and yeah it's
cool is it being
cool as it was as it was have been was
it as cool of an experience to and
lunatics as anything else
yeah well cooling better in the way that
it rates people because normally I have
to like launch it in different countries
and you kind of dealing with different
networks but this was just like they
just press the button and suddenly it's
all over the world yeah it's a big
audience so about making the show was
pretty much the same experience I guess
as all of them because yeah it's so
crazy as sudden like there are moments
where I look at you and I'll see like
just like another character popping in
my head that it's like I forgot about a
little bit I really you know even from
the past yeah there'll be like an angle
where it's like oh there's a mr. G you
know or they like an angle and then
they're like oh that's [ __ ] you know
oh I see how he's built that's how Jonah
was built you know like if just like the
way your arm is bent it's just kind of
bizarre man you know yeah it's really
cool I didn't see myself I guess I don't
really get that experience unless
something's looking the mirrow something
but yeah I can imagine that must be we
people often do try to say who they
think I'm the most like they'd write a
lot but that must change though because
then suddenly there are moments where
I'm like oh he definitely seems like
Gavin a little bit more you know yeah
the Earl of what is it called
gasps yeah [ __ ] great
Chris Lilley man thank you so much I
don't think there's anything else really
I mean we can kind of chill and wrap it
up is that okay with you yeah that
sounds good it's been really fun
has it been yeah I didn't know what to
expect but it's been so relaxed and
you're very easy to talk to
well thanks man I appreciate it yeah I
wanted this to be just uh I mean I think
this would be a great episode man our
listeners are gonna absolutely be over
the moon just to have to be able to have
like it's just an experience with you
just as a regular person you know and um
yeah it's just inspiring man it's
inspiring to see like because there's
nothing else out there like you so
people need to see it and young people
need to see it so they can be reminded I
can oh I all can do that you know yeah
because that's how I learned about stuff
watch it I would see in living color and
like Damon Wayans and something like oh
I can do that that's a thing yeah
Wow now I'm gonna do that you know like
a kid sending me videos all the time of
characters like they doesn't buy right
yeah it's fun that would be great um do
you plan to will you make more stuff in
the future you're not gonna you don't
have any plans on quitting being
creative do you not at all no I love
doing this and it's so fun good can't
wait to do more cool brother Chris
Lilley ladies and gentlemen check out
lunatics and then go back if you haven't
and watch Summer Heights High Jonah from
Tonga and and you'll fall into the rest
of the world and and tell your friends
about it because yeah for some reason
man summer night sighs the greatest gift
I can give to any of my friends at
heaven I'm like have you seen this and
when they say no I'm just like ah
[ __ ] Merry Christmas [ __ ] you
know it's fun
thank you brother thanks yeah
[Music]
little time for me to set that parking
brake
Oh
[Music]